in doing so they attract three
unidentified objects one Alaska Canada
and over Lake Huron in the Midwest
they act in accordance with established
parameters for determining how to deal
with unidentified aerial objects in U.S
airspace
at third recommendation I gave the order
to take down these three objects due to
hazards to civilian commercial air
traffic and because we could not rule
out the surveillance risk of sensitive
facilities
we acted in consultation with the
Canadian government I spoke personally
with prime minister Trudeau and Kant
from Canada on Saturday
and just as critically we acted out of
an abundance of caution and an
opportunity that allowed us to take down
these these objects safely
our military and the Canadian military
are seeking to recover the debris so we
can learn more about these three objects
our intelligence Community is still
assessing all three incidences they're
reporting to me daily and will continue
their urgent efforts to do so and I will
communicate that to the Congress
we don't yet know exactly what these
three objects were but nothing nothing
right now suggests they were related to
China's spy balloon program or that
there were surveillance vehicles from
other any other country
the intelligence community's current
assessment is that these three objects
were most likely balloons tied to
private companies Recreation or research
institutions studying weather or
conducting other scientific research